how's it going everybody we have some
recent updates on Captain Marvel
guardians of the galaxy actor Lee pace
who played Ronan the accuser in the
movie has recently shared a video to his
Twitter if you thought guardians of the
galaxy was the end of Ronan the accuser
surprise surprise it was not Ronan the
accuser will be returning in Captain
Marvel which takes place before the
events of guardians of the galaxy just a
reminder that the Avengers infinity war
blu-ray giveaway continues all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts on it and your
favorite superhero I'll be picking
another winner on Monday so be sure to
enter Captain Marvel will have both Kree
and scroll in the movie and of course
the radical kree fanatic wrote in the
accuser will be making his return actor
Lee pace who plays ronan has recently
uploaded a video to his Twitter of him
walking around with a Captain Marvel cap
on many fans have speculated that this
is Lee arriving on set to film Captain
Marvel
however this looks like he might be on
vacation because you can see that he is
in France because you can see the Pont
du Gard in the background so is Lee on
vacation or could this possibly be a
place where they're filming and does it
mean anything or is Lee simply promoting
the movie that he's going to be in hard
to tell right now but let me know your
thoughts in the comments below again
don't forget to enter the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is like this video subscribe to my
channel and comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]